work has been halted at the site of that
collapsed apartment high rise in
surfside florida
amid fears that parts of the building
still standing
could give way u.s president joe biden
is in surfside tonight where he has been
briefed on the emergency operation he
met with first responders and thanked
them for their work
and is also holding a closed door
meeting with the families of people
who have been killed and of those who
are still missing
the confirmed death toll has risen to 18
with as many as 145
unaccounted for no survivors have been
found
since last thursday
it's hard to think about anything else
for diana winner
every time she takes the dog out she
passes by the collapsed champlain
tower diana's aunt survived but hopes of
finding more people alive are fading
she believes the tragedy could have been
avoided
i feel sad i feel sad that people didn't
really
step up and say it's time we need to
we need to pay attention to this and do
what we need to do
it's too many lives have probably been
lost
as a result of it for days hundreds of
firefighters were picking through the
rubble
the rescue operation is now halted as
expanding cracks and other instabilities
in the structure pose danger to their
lives digging was already slow because
of the risk of further collapses
the workers emotions are another
obstacle
it's very sad on me the times that i've
been going up on the pile and you
find strollers and baby bottles um
stuffed toys you know it's it just
brings a
sense of reality to to the moment you
know it's um
it's very touching because i have i have
kids myself
a 2018 inspection warrant of structural
damages to the building the focus is now
on
similar high-rises in the county 40
years and older
inspectors are now checking 40 other
high-rise buildings for damages
a large effort that could still not be
enough if the owners
don't have enough money to get the
necessary works done in case of the
champlain towers
the necessary repairs could have cost
100 000 u.s dollars per unit
daryl arnold who lives opposite the
champlain towers believes something has
to change
he has his own theory on why the
building wasn't repaired despite the
findings of structural damage
what happened in this case is the city
official inspector
said that there was um
you know nothing to worry about
imminently and people breathed probably
a sigh of relief because they didn't
want to find the money
to deal with the problem i assume that's
going to change
in light of this incident and you're
going to have much more care and caution
going forward much healing is needed in
surfside florida
but for now the beach community is
reeling from this historic
tragedy
and our oliver salad is in surf side
florida right now good evening to you
oliver can the u.s president at this
stage can he
offer the families any hope that their
missing loved ones will be found alive
it's really a balancing act brand uh
president biden has been spending the
last hours
behind closed doors meeting and talking
to the
relatives of the victims the potential
victims of course of those who are still
unaccounted for
and he's really trying to find words of
sympathy but then also encouraging words
because many have still hopes that their
relatives could be found underneath the
rubble just a little while ago we heard
that rescuers heard the voice of a woman
under the rubble
miami-dade fire rescue chief confirmed
that however no one was found at first
aside and all everyone who's missing a
female relative of not now of course
desperately putting his hopes up
waiting for that miracle to happen
because the last survivor as you
mentioned
has been found one week ago in the early
hours after the tower came down
yeah and the dangers apparently are
still there at the site what more do we
know about the situation there
well the rescue operation has
been paused essentially because of the
dangers of
further parts of the standing
construction the tower that has not
come down that this could collapse as
well so there is a lot of fear of course
that the rescuers are in danger and that
potentially those who might
survive underneath underneath the rubble
are in even more danger now if
more parts of the building comes down
other than that there's it's a really
careful operation we've seen that
yesterday when we filmed there people
really carefully with gloves with
with their bare hands trying to sift
through the rubble
and that is also why everything takes so
long and do we know
our authorities are they any clear on
what caused this tower to collapse
well there is some kind of a lead that
has been developed over the last days
we've heard of this 2018
inspection that found some structural
damages at the building
we also know that the president of the
condominium association
just a few months ago wrote in a letter
to the owners that the situation has
deteriorated he spoke of
50 million us dollars in repairs that
would be urgently needed but that of
course is a contrasting account to the
city inspector who thought the situation
was less urgent
and as it seems the owner went with his
assessment
so all of this looks very plausible
right now but of course it's also
important to point out
that we have to wait until an
investigation is finished and that will
take several months from now
and what about the concern that other
buildings are at risk of collapsing
there's of course some concern because
there are many of these older
buildings along the east coast of the
united states and many are being
investigated right now
40 of them only here in this county the
problem of course and that we've we've
learned that painfully from the collapse
here in surfside
is that knowing the damages doesn't
necessarily mean that they are being
fixed and so the hopes are that some
legal action might follow
and i was able to speak to a board
member of another condominium
building and she said that it would be
useful to
force owners to sell their condominiums
if they can't afford the necessary
repairs certainly a tough measure
but perhaps one way to avoid such a
situation from happening again
our very own oliver salad in surfside
florida tonight
oliver thank you